♪♪
THE FIRST THING I TOOK APART
WAS MY MOTHER'S TELEPHONE,
AND I TOOK ALL THE PIECES APART.
AND THEN I PUT IT BACK TOGETHER,
BUT I NAILED IT TO A BOARD.
AND SO, EVERYONE WAS TALKING
ON THE PHONE ON THIS BOARD,
WITH THE DIALER OVER HERE AND
THE RINGER OVER HERE, YOU KNOW.
THAT WAS MY FIRST EXPLORATION
IN DECONSTRUCTION
AND RECONSTRUCTION.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE OPENING
A PRESENT.
YOU HAVE THIS WONDERFUL THING,
AND THEN YOU KIND OF PEEL BACK
THESE LAYERS
AND SEE HOW IT FUNCTIONS.
I THINK THERE'S THE DISCOVERY
OF TAKING THINGS APART
THAT IS THE MOST EXCITING THING.
I HAVE BEEN TAKING THINGS APART
SINCE I WAS VERY LITTLE.
I STILL REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME
I TOOK APART THIS OLD CAMERA.
I JUST, LIKE, CUT THE END
OFF ANOTHER POWER CORD,
PLUGGED IT INTO THAT,
AND SPARKS WENT EVERYWHERE.
AND, YEAH, THE MAGIC SMOKE
GOT OUT.
[ LAUGHS ]
FEELS LIKE CHRISTMAS MORNING.
I ACTUALLY LOVE TO TAKE THINGS
APART THAT OTHER PEOPLE BUILT
BECAUSE YOU GET TO REALLY
FIGURE OUT HOW THAT WORKS
AND WHY THEY MADE THAT DECISION.
THERE'S A LOT OF REALLY
INTERESTING SUBTLETIES
THAT WENT INTO IT ON THE GOOD
DESIGNS AND THE BAD DESIGNS.
AND SO YOU CAN LEARN
FROM BOTH OF THEM.
YOU LEARN WHAT TO DO
AND WHAT NOT TO DO.